la trappiste nadia et député de la 11e
circonscription des yvelines a été nommé
ministre délégué à la ville dans le
cadre du remaniement du gouvernement du
premier ministre jean castex
elle s'est exprimé ce lundi 6 juillet
sur les réseaux sociaux se disant prête
à relever le défi
révélé en 2017 au moment des
législatives dans la bague la république
en marche après l'élection du président
emmanuel macron cet ancien cadre dans la
banque s'engage en politique en créant
le comité femmes en marche avec macron
issus de la société civile la trappiste
se lance aux élections législatives
la même année pour la 11e
circonscription l affront de benoît
hamon candidat génération et jean michel
fourgous investi par les républicains
les deux précédents député de la
circonscription au second tour des
élections elle est élu avec 52 96% des
voix contre 47,0 4%
pour jean michel fourgous afin de
septembre elle devient députée des
yvelines
je suis effectivement extrêmement
satisfaite des du résultat après après
-selon semaine de travail
ces longues semaines on te suis allé à
la rencontre de nous de nos concitoyens
et c'est aussi une grande fierté
aujourd'hui pour moi d'en arriver là au
sein de l'assemblée nationale
elle devient membre de la commission des
finances et fait partie du groupe
d'étude villes et banlieues en tant que
vice présidente aux finances
pour son nouveau poste de ministre
délégué à la ville auprès de la ministre
de la cohésion des territoires
elle pourra s'appuyer sur cette
expérience une expérience de terrain
lorsqu'elle travaillait sur les
questions politiques de la ville
notamment à trappes et à la verrière de
villes de sa circonscription
ce lundi 6 juillet en apprenant sa
nomination au gouvernement elle a
démissionné de son poste de député des
élections législatives partielles seront
donc organisées pour élire son
successeur